let's get to the point you know how I
feel two weeks ago I said we needed to
flatten the curve not the economy
I warned that the cure could be worse
than the disease because poverty kills
despair kills of course the virus is
deadly but so is this shutdown you just
won't see its victims in a neat little
box on cable news we need to honor the
victims of the virus and families who've
lost loved ones it is totally wrong for
anyone to dismiss or minimize the pain
and suffering from the corona virus
pandemic or to ignore the federal or
state guidelines but it's just as wrong
to dismiss or minimize the pain and
suffering from the corona virus shut
down well we have tried to capture that
toll in a neat little box on cable news
already confirmed at least nine point
nine million Americans have lost their
job that doesn't even include the
self-employed the trillions in rescue
money that'll have to be paid for at
some point if you divide the current
total between every taxpayer it's an
average of $45,000 of course it'll be
much more the current package will only
last a few weeks hundreds of thousands
of businesses going under many more in
September and October when the real
crunch comes more on that in a moment
then the projected toll based on what
happened in the Great Recession and
great depression although this shutdown
is looking like it will be worse than
both of those combined a mental health
crisis in America mass poverty which
inexorably leads to lower life
expectancy past experience predicts that
more human life will be lost from a
prolonged shutdown than the models
predict will be lost from this virus
those models were presented to the
president last Sunday and all of us on
Tuesday
they're the reason the shutdown was
extended to the 30th of April what they
didn't tell you was this from the man
who created one of the main models that
our models assumed that the social
distancing stays in place right through
the end of May to get the trajectory
that we see and it you know we hope that
that you know could be as few as 80,000
deaths or even less
they said the shutdown will last until
April the 30th
but it seems like it's actually June the
first at least since these models are
driving one of the most significant
policy decisions in the history of this
country it's reasonable to investigate
them the 2.2 million death toll that was
on a chart in the White House briefing
room it came from Imperial College
London but it's been debunked by some
public health experts his Stanford
epidemiologist dr. John Ioannidis
we have more complete information about
that denominator suggest that the
infection fatality rate is much much
lower than 3.4 percent it is actually
probably much lower compared to the 0.9%
that is the main figure that went into
some influential calculations by a
wonderful team of researchers in
Imperial College which probably
overestimated the the exact infection
fatality risk the projection of a
hundred thousand to two hundred and
forty thousand deaths even with a total
national shot down lasting until at
least June the first the factors that
went into that calculation include data
from Italy which has also been
questioned by epidemiologists here's dr.
Yanni this again it would not be
surprising if in some locations in
Lombardy we have currently reached
infection rates of 20 or even 30 percent
but this is still a bit speculative if
that's the case then you need to correct
the infection fatality rate or case
fatality rate for Italy that seems to be
very high by a very large factor it
could be a correction of a hundred for
example that needs to be applied but ok
let's ignore the public health experts
questioning the data and take the
projections at face value even the worst
case scenario presented last week will
be dwarfed by the long-term human toll
of this shutdown more human life across
a much broader range will be lost in the
UK the government is modelling the
health impact of the shutdown as well as
the virus our government should do that
here and be clear the public
health experts are saying that when the
shutdown is lifted the virus will come
back
so if shutdown remains the only policy
we would need many more of them for at
least another year the public health
experts tell us the shutdown is annoying
and inconvenient but we just have to
accept it if you lose your job and your
family's relying on it for a roof over
their head that's not annoying it's
terrifying if your business collapses
after you've put your life into it and
secure your home against it that's not
inconvenient it's a disaster from which
you may never recover if we truly want
to save lives all lives then we need to
do two things slow the spread but speed
the shutdown it must end
as soon as safely possible but that
means we need a better antivirus policy
than we have right now last week I said
open where possible closed where
necessary shutdowns do slow the spread
look at the difference between the bay
area which had the nation's first stay
at home orders a new york city so right
now in the absence of a better antivirus
policy it is necessary to shut things
down everywhere that includes Utah
Wyoming Oklahoma Arkansas Nebraska North
Dakota South Dakota Iowa South Carolina
where there are no statewide stay at
home orders tonight I'm asking those
governor's including a great friend of
this show Iowa's Kim Reynolds to put in
place a stay at home order at least for
the duration of president Trump's slow
the spread guidelines of course that
will take a high toll in these states
and on our country and there it is jobs
businesses livelihoods and lives
remember this is not a choice between
public health and the economy between
lives and money the shot down costs
lives too
the president knows this and that's why
he organized the biggest and quickest
rescue package for America's workers
families and small businesses we've ever
seen but even though they deleted Nancy
Pelosi zuv woke wish list there are
still some bad things in there I want to
focus on one that could have serious
consequences the small business paycheck
protection program covers the costs of
payroll rent health insurance interests
and utilities for eight weeks but the
amount that small businesses can get is
based on their payroll costs only rent
isn't taken into account at all that is
crazy
rent is a huge cost for most companies
so many entrepreneurs have told me
you've got to get the president to
change this many landlords right now are
doing the decent thing and saying you
can miss payments for the next two or
three months but those landlords have
bills to pay too and so they're going to
add it back on to rent payments in a few
months
small businesses with tight margins
won't survive that right now the worst
of the shutdown toll is the jobs crash
but because of this problem with a
paycheck protection program small
businesses right across the country will
be going bust in August September
October just when the economy is
supposed to come roaring back just
before the election
Steve minuchin has been great in this
crisis but all that work will be for
nothing if small businesses collapse
because of this technical problem we can
see that the president and his team are
totally focused on winning the war
against the invisible enemy the
coronavirus in the middle east we got
bogged down in endless wars because no
one knew what the objective was or had a
realistic plan for achieving it but the
coronavirus it should be clear it is not
realistic or achievable to say no one
should ever get infected the goal should
be to stop our hospitals becoming
overwhelmed so the immediate task is to
slow the spread and surge our capacity
the extra ICU beds the ventilators the
PPE that is happening that is today's
battle but it's not how we win the war
and neither is shut down because when
you lift the shutdown the virus comes
back the American people will not put up
much longer being told there is no
alternative they want to know their
leaders are working on a more
sustainable antivirus policy they
understand we need to slow the spread
but what they also want to see is a plan
for speeding up the shutdown
and we are planning to bring you one
next Sunday
if you agree with this message follow us
at Steve Hilton X and that next row of
fnc and share this when we post it